[Musique]
bonsoir à tous alors j'ai un aveu à vous
faire j'ai une sorte de phobie
je n'ai aucune envie de tomber malade
alors je vous ai rennais mes médicaments
les plus précieux qui m'ont été prescrit
par un médecin de grande renommée
j'ai avec moi un anti-inflammatoire un
antioxydant un anticholestérol et puis
un petit régulateur intestinale
alors il y en a peut-être parmi vous qui
ont les mêmes phobique moi en tout cas
je vais faire un plaisir de partager
avec vous mes petits secrets
alors voici mon anti cholestérol pour ça
sa teneur en pectine elle va réduire la
portion des graisses voici mon
antioxydants qui ralentit le
vieillissement
je vous avais dit un médicament était
fantastique
on va simon régulateur intestinale
acquis au sirop minéralisant tu chi chi
et dynamisante et voici une anti
inflammatoire absolument prodigieux et
je vous invite à essayer et s'agit j'ai
une d'un réseau de curcuma ferait donc
qui est très efficace pour toutes les
petites douleurs rhumatismes et c'est
donc vous l'avez peut être deviné je
faisais référence à l'adage bien connu
sous le nom d'hippocrate que ton aliment
soit ton médicament parce que nous
sommes ici ce soir pour parler des
bienfaits d'une alimentation naturelle
pour notre santé alors justement en
parlant de santé vous avez peut-être
comme moi des convictions qui datent de
l'enfance qui nous sont transmis par les
parents l'école mais aussi les
la santé publique je vais les illustrés
ici avec la pyramide alimentaire qui
nous est fournie par le programme
national de santé qui nous recommandent
de manger des céréales des fruits et les
légumes des produits laitiers de la
viande et de limiter les graisses et les
sucres
alors comment être sûr que cette
pyramide alimentaire est vraiment le
fruit de nos besoins nutritionnels mais
ou alors qu'elle n'est pas l'objet de
pressions des gros industriels
alimentaires alors ce soir je vais vous
demander d'oublier toutes vos références
alimentaires parce qu'on va aller voir
ce que la nature a réellement prévu pour
nous alors je vais vous proposer une
petite introspection sur notre anatomie
qu'on va aller comparer avec les celles
des herbivores des fruits givors et des
carnivores alors juste un petit peu de
théorie
d'abord les membres alors les carnivores
on est griffes acérées
nous on a plus tôt
donc dès les mains avec des ongles plat
qui nous permettent pas justement
d'aller chasser un manu on est plutôt
fait pour la cueillette du coup si on
compare aux frugivores notre dentition
la dentition des carnivores et donc des
dents très aiguisé qui permet aussi
d'aller chasser et tuer leurs proies
tandis que les frugivores les herbivores
ont des dents plate comme nous donc on a
des dents plate tout à l'heure geoffrey
vous a dit de mâcher et bien nous sommes
plutôt prédisposé pour mâcher donc des
fruits et des légumes
même si on regarde le bonobo là qui
apparaît est un singe végétariens et là
des canines plus pointu que nous alors
ensuite on passe aux intestins les
intestins des carnivores sont très
courts parce qu'ils permettent de de ne
pas assimiler toutes les toxines qui
sont contenus dans les chairs animale
les intestins des frugivores au
contraire sont plus longs il faut à peu
près 12 fois la longueur du torse pour
assimiler manière optimale tous les
glucides et les nutriments contenus dans
les fruits et nous at il donc de
comparaison nous sommes proches
on a la même longueur des intestins que
les frugivores ensuite les reins alors
je vais terminer par les reins ma
comparaison dons qui permettent
l'élimination de tous les déchets les
carnivores ont des reins très forts qui
permettent d'assimiler de d'éliminer
plus tôt tout l'acide urique qui est
présent dans la chair animale tandis que
les frugivores ont des reins plutôt
faible puisque les fruits laisse peu de
déchet et nous nous avons des reins qui
sont assez faibles
malheureusement nous ne savons pas
éliminer une grosse quantité d'acide
urique
on va donc le stocker donc je pourrais
continuer encore longtemps cette
comparaison mais vous en auriez marre
donc en conclusion on voit bien qu au
niveau de son anatomie le
l'homme est très proche des frugivores
on serait naturellement frugivores mais
par contre notre consommation
cela vous serez d'accord avec moi nous
sommes un niveau or on consomme un petit
peu pas mal de choses donc des laitages
les céréales il est la viande les sucres
les graisses et c est donc l impact de
dévier de notre alimentation naturelle
et bien l'impact c'est que tous ces
éléments sont acidifiant et l'acidité
alors il ya un principe à connaître en
fait notre corps à un équilibre à
respecter qui est de tendre vers la
neutralité du péage de son sang et quand
nous mangeons des éléments qui sont
acidifiant eh bien on des règles ses
rangs fonctionnement et il est obligé de
lutter alors comment ils luttent et bien
il va chercher des minéraux dans notre
corps d'abord et où va-t-il les trouver
et bain par exemple dans nos eaux dans
notre cartilage et dans nos dents
puisque il m'a cherchée du calcium mais
ça engendre aussi d'autres dérèglements
de la fatigue de des calculs rénaux des
difficultés intestinale tout ça pour me
dire que peut-être notre alimentation
est acide et puis on n'est pas aidé par
les événements extérieurs parce que tout
notre monde conduit à une acidification
les émotions négatives le stress les
consommations d'alcool et de tabac
alors comment faire et bien la nature
nous donne les éléments pour rectifier
le tir et nous permettre d'alcalinité
notre corps donc tous les fruits et les
légumes vont être alkali misant et nous
permettre de retrouver un équilibre
alors dans quelle mesure alors il faut
manger une grosse quantité d'éléments
alcalines nisand à peu près 80% pour
faire face à 20% d'éléments acidifiant
dans le
dans cet équilibre optimal mais ce n'est
pas la seule révélation je voudrais vous
faire ce soir
je voudrais vous faire une révélation
stupéfiante sur le lien entre
l'alimentation et la santé
c'est il s'agit du rapport cambell dont
qui a été le fruit d'une étude de 40 ans
et d une collaboration d université de
cornell de standford et l'académie de
médecine préventive alors que nous dit
ce rapport
eh bien d'abord que toutes les
nutriments nécessaires à notre santé
sont présents dans une alimentation
végétale avec des rapports d idéal donc
des proportions idéales et pour nous
permettre une assimilation optimale nous
c'est à dire que si on avait peur de
manquer de protéines de calcium ou de
faire et bien on peut très bien se
contenter d'une alimentation végétale et
être en pleine santé seule la b12 pas
nous manquer et il faudra supplémenté
mais c'est pas ma révélation préférée
c'est celle qui suit alors il ya une
certaine fatalité face aux maladies
qu'on pourrait développer avec notre
capital génétique
on savait déjà que certes certains gènes
pouvait s activer ou non
dur tout au long de notre vie certains
gènes porteurs de maladies eh bien ils
découvrent que nous avons que vous avez
le pouvoir parce que ce sont les
protéines animales la viande et le lait
qui vont activer certains gènes qui sont
porteurs de maladies telles que le
cancer les maladies cardiovasculaires ou
les le diabète ou le cholestérol
cela veut dire qu'on peut prendre en
main sa santé et
enrayer la tendance et qu'en tout cas
même une faible baisse de consommation
de protéines animales à des effets déjà
très très bénéfiques sur notre santé
alors concrètement moi j'ai choisi de
d'éliminer toutes les protéines animales
de mon alimentation donc la viande les
produits laitiers etc et je suis
tellement persuadé des effets bénéfiques
pour la santé que j'en ai fait mon
métier
j'anime des ateliers cuisine végétale
donc à destination des adultes et des
enfants pour faire découvrir justement
que la cuisine végétale peut permettre
d'allier la santé et le goût et le
plaisir de manger
alors je sais pas si vous avez entendu
parler d'un mouvement en cuisine qui qui
est en recrudescence et qu'ils
développent de par le monde
il s'agit de l'alimentation vivante ou
de la cuisine crû de la raw food stase
unis il s'agit d'une alimentation 100 %
naturelle basée sur les fruits et les
légumes et qui permet de sublimer ces
éléments on amène aussi des super
aliments des halles des graines décret n
g remixé et on va garder toute leur
vitalité
alors comment garder préserver leurs
nutriments et bien il s'agit de limiter
leur cuisson
parce qu'au delà de 45 degrés on
commence déjà à détruire les enzymes
digestives la vitamine c est ensuite
l'ensemble des vitamines
par exemple des 110 degrés donc pour une
cuisson à basse température à la vapeur
et bien on détruit déjà 50% des
vitamines
alors cette alimentation est basé sur
énormément de fruits parce que les
fruits sont une source d'aliments
d'énergie optimale pour les humains
alors on l'a vu tout à l'heure notre
conception
anatomique et plutôt frugivores et c'est
un peu sur ce principe que s'appuient
l'alimentation vivante et alors que en
étant un univers on mange énormément de
céréales et de pins et on se dit qu'on
va y trouver son énergie et pourtant
vous avez peut-être remarqué votre petit
somnolence à 14 heures qui est en fait
le poids du à cette digestion parce que
une digestion de céréales et et autres
viandes va prendre 50% de votre énergie
vitale alors qu une digestion de fruits
va libérer davantage d'énergie et au
contraire on va pas se sentir alourdi
alors on va aussi consommer des légumes
et les légumes sont le pouvoir d'être un
peu dépuratif pour notre organisme
alors on peut les consommer sous forme
de jus ce qui va permettre une remise la
réalisation complète de notre corps et
en les consommant avant le repas et bien
on ap en a fait des rappels son système
digestif
on pourra bénéficier des nutriments
immédiatement et puis si on aime le lait
et bien on peut trouver le plaisir des
laits végétaux qui offre une multitude
de goûts et de saveurs qu'on peut
réaliser soi même ou à acheter et moi ce
que j'aime danser les végétaux sait
qu'on peut les cuisiner parce qu'on ne
dit pas adieu à la gourmandise dans la
cuisine cru au contraire on va pouvoir
pâtisser cru
c'est à dire qu'on va allier la
gourmandise avec il à la préservation de
la santé oms va cuisiner des sucres
naturels on va cuisiner des fruits secs
des fruits et on va obtenir des choses
succulente et qui sont naturels pour
notre corps alors vous avez découvert ce
soir que notre alimentation avait des
pouvoirs insoupçonnés le pouvoir de vous
maintenir en bonne santé
en revenant à une alimentation naturelle
on peut avoir des bénéfices
insoupçonnées alors maintenant je vous
encourage je vous invite
à prendre soin de vous soin de vos
enfants soin de votre famille de vos
amis parce que la santé est ce que nous
avons de plus précieux
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]